The next location, pause the video, try to pronounce this word.
Yeah, this very, very long Norwegian word translates to "Atlantic Ocean Road."
Now, it is known as the world's most dangerous road just because during the wintertime,...
...there are very strong storms that go through this area.
When I did this drive, it was actually a beautiful sunny day,...
...so I didn't get to experience it in the storm and the craziness,...
...but still I could imagine it can be pretty menacing in the storm.
It is eight total bridges long and 8,274 meters.
And this is the biggest tip of this video.
If you are going to Norway, you make videos and you make photos.
Invest in a drone.
The drone is the only way to really, really see this country,...
...which brings us to our next location.